[Music]
hey there guys and welcome to a new
series for the bio near humanly possible
I'll be focusing on the coolest feats
powers and skills from fiction to see if
anything like them is remotely humanly
possible
and to begin with I'll be looking at the
bullet foo or gun cata seen in movies
like John wick the matrix equilibrium
and anything directed by John Woo
not to mention games like Max Payne and
my friend Pedro martial arts movies have
been accused of being redundant what
good is it to be a top-class living
weapon when someone can just pull a gun
on you of course a gunfight is typically
far shorter and less balletic
than your average kung-fu throwdown and
thus less cinematic therefore gun foo
was born highly stylized gunplay that
turns shooting people into a beautiful
choreographed dance because why not
so is it humanly possible can you really
dodged a bullet is kung fu any use
against the gun or can you at least take
on a squad of henchmen in cool style
with any chance of success
let's start with dodging bullets
the short answer here is no you cannot
dodge a bullet
this is physically impossible due to a
number of different factors not least
the fact that it takes too long for the
signal to travel through your nervous
system the very fastest nerve impulse
travels at roughly 250 miles an hour
though this depends on the type of nerve
and the time it takes for a signal to
travel from your brain to your hand is
about not 0.3 seconds this isn't even
counting the amount of time it takes for
visual information to travel from the
eye to the brain so that you know you
need to dodge in the first place this
takes about 13 milliseconds then you
need to actually process all that and
decide what you're going to do which
direction you're going to dodge in for
instance what's more is that this
information is actually delayed for the
same amount of time it takes for the
brain to receive the last input from the
body normally the proprioceptors of the
foot in other words all information
waits so that it can come in at the same
time and all appears to be in sync this
is so that for example when you tap your
foot you see it at the same time as you
feel it as Michael from Vsauce explains
in an excellent video that also means
unfortunately that taller people have
slightly slower reaction times and it
means that we all live very slightly in
the past everything you see in here has
already happened now consider that a
typical handgun fires at 2,500 feet per
second thus in naught point three
seconds it is traveled 750 feet in other
words you're not dodging it should come
as no surprise then to learn there's no
such thing as real-life gun kata there
are martial arts designed around
fighting with guns using them as blunt
instruments for instance but as far as a
real-life gun cutter or gun foo is
concerned nope doesn't exist so someone
pulls a gun to your head and you're dead
right well not quite in a fascinating
experiment to participants of equal
skill a faced opposite one another one
has a handgun one does not the unarmed
subject is instructed to stand with
their hands up and to attempt to disarm
their opponent as soon as they see an
opportunity the gun man meanwhile is
instructed to fire as soon as they see
the other person move now you'd think
that in this situation the unarmed
participant
would lose every time however almost the
exact opposite is true in nearly every
case the gun-toting operator loses keep
in mind that this experiment was not
published in a peer-reviewed journal
that was conducted at the Suarez
International training facility as
reported in black belt magazine to take
it with a pinch of salt but that said
there's actually a good explanation for
what may be going on here
we cannot dodge bullets due to
limitations in the processing speed of a
human brain but there's also the
limitation we can use against our
opponents why because if someone is
pointing a gun at you and hasn't already
fired then they're likely waiting for
you to do something maybe hand over your
cash or pray for your life now that
means you can plan ahead you know what
you're going to do next
whereas they have to react to that thing
visualize a plan of attack first and you
might just be able to pull it off this
is due to something called the OODA loop
first outlined by a military strategist
: all of John Boyd this acronym stands
for observe orient decide and act and
describes the stages that we need to go
through when engaging in any action
these four stages are each estimated to
take at least one quarter of a second by
pre-planning you can essentially
therefore gain a small advantage over
your opponent this is called getting
inside that you de loop a similar trick
island in karate is to use a form of
distraction by talking and then
attacking mid-sentence the human brain
is naturally programmed to wait for the
end of a sentence and task switching in
this interrupted manner takes even more
time and processing best are waiting for
you to finish talking and you've just
hit them square in the face this is an
example of breaking anniversaries you
deliver through chaos and uncertainty
the more chaos and confusion you can
cause the harder it will be for your
opponent to adapt and respond there are
other ways you can get inside an
opponent's sudha loop - one is to
identify potential threats and orient
yourself correctly before an encounter
this can of course be improved by
developing better situational awareness
remaining undetected for as long as
possible is also a powerful strategy so
while you can't outmaneuver a gun you
might just be able to use psychology to
your advantage of course your own
psychology must also be for lack of a
better word bullet proof you must be
good at making snap decisions under
extreme pressure and remaining calmly
aware of your
things at all times nor'easter complain
apparently the best-performing Marines
and athletes are those that produce
greater amounts of neuropeptide Y and
DHEA when in stressful situations this
allows them to maintain a metronomic
heart rate so they're calm we can
improve our own ability to remain calm
and alert by using breathing techniques
such as their fourfold breath also
taught to military personnel a moment's
hesitation and you're dead and this is
something that is conveyed really well
in John wick he's extremely efficient
with every movement and his unflinching
expression is a testament to how commies
through even the most intense firefight
that's some pretty good casting there so
his gun through realistic then no not at
all and I highly recommend that if
someone ever pulls a gun on you you do
exactly what they ask and then you get
out of there all it takes is for them to
have a knee-jerk reaction to pull that
trigger and it's game over but perhaps
with the right psychology strategy
steely determination and decades of
training an assassin like John wick
could ever say slightly tip the scales
to their advantage in a gunfight and
that's still pretty cool and we can all
benefit from situational awareness and
understanding the OODA loop to apply in
other aspects of our lives we can all
learn something from John wick thanks
ton for watching guys I hope you found
this video useful and interesting if you
did then please leave a like share
around that helps me out immensely
thanks a ton to commenter captain Ralph
for suggesting this video on John wick
which also led to the whole idea for
this humanly possible series if you have
any other suggestions for topics for me
to cover in this series then please do
let me know and of course subscribe if
you want to see that as well as much
more next week I'm gonna be covering
neck training and I've got lots of cool
interesting stuff on the way if you
really enjoy the content on this channel
then check out the link below which will
take you to the pre-order page from my
ebook super-functional training the
general concept behind this is a
training program that's not only for
building muscle but also for brain
training for improving focus
concentration creativity quick thinking
as well as pretty much every other
aspect of your performance such as
mobility balance etc essentially I don't
know why exercise for most people means
just training your bicep
and your abs and if you agree then check
out the book I think you'll find it
really interesting if you preorder now
you'll save $10 off the eventual price
as well as gaining some extra materials
and the release date is November the 4th
so not too far away now anyways thanks a
ton for watching this guys and I'll see
you next time bye for now